[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAVI KIRAN KUMAR: What
is Cloud Identity?
It's a cloud-based identity
and access management
solution and a device
management solution.
So you have two
solutions packaged
into one single
product, Cloud Identity.
So it gives you a single
pane of glass for you
to manage all your
users and devices
and also applications, all
from one single pane of glass.
And it also brings
BeyondCorp security model
to your enterprises.
How many of you have heard or
know about BeyondCorp security
model?
OK, about 30% of the room.
So I won't go very
deep into BeyondCorp
because it takes
the entire session.
But I wanted to give you a quick
one-minute intro on BeyondCorp,
because that's very important.
BeyondCorp is the
next-generation security model
that Google conceived
a few years ago.
And there are two key tenets
based on from a BeyondCorp
security model perspective.
The first one is
no-trust networks.
You're not even trusting
your own network.
What we do is we inspect
each and every request that's
coming to your
applications, and we
make sure that these requests
are authenticated, authorized,
and also encrypted.
And the second key thing from
a BeyondCorp security model
perspective is that we go beyond
the traditional identity-based
access.
So we also look at the
context of the request,
where the request is coming
from, what kind of device
you're using.
Are you using a company-owned
device or a BYOD device?
What kind of security posture
do you have on the device?
So there are a lot of
things that we look
at from a context perspective.
And then you'll be able to
create these granular access
control permissions
on your application.
So that's the BeyondCorp.
So Cloud Identity
is the vehicle that
brings BeyondCorp security
model for your IT and business
applications.
And also, Cloud Identity
is the identity layer
that powers G Suite
and GCP applications.
It's been there for some time.
We have hundreds of
thousands of customers
who are using Cloud Identity,
about billions of users.
And it's also offered as a
standalone product starting
March of last year in 2018.
And when you look
at Cloud Identity,
it includes all
the key components
that you normally look for
in a full-fledged identity
and access management
platform, like user lifecycle
management, account security,
multi-factor authentication,
single sign-on into your
internal applications,
external applications,
third-party SaaS-based
applications, APIs
for extensibility,
and reporting, auditing for
your compliance purposes,
and most importantly, the open
standards adherence-- so SAML,
OpenID Connect, OAuth,
[? Skim, ?] and whatnot.
And now you may ask,
hey, what about some
of the on-premise
applications that I have?
So we recognize that the
SaaS-based application adoption
is going through the roof for
small business, medium, large.
Regardless of what's the
size of your business,
everyone is using
SaaS-based applications.
But like Sundar said
yesterday in the keynote, most
of the large
companies, they still
have majority of
their applications
and infrastructure on-premise
for a variety of reasons.
So you may probably
need some more time
to migrate, or
retire, or modernize.
But what happens is, in
this particular case,
giving your employees
a way to access
these modern applications
and legacy applications
in a simple way is
really challenging.
And it forces your IT teams
to start maintaining these two
different identity systems--
one for modern applications, one
for on-premise applications--
which increases your cost
and, most importantly,
the complexity.
So for those of
you who said, we're
using Active Directory, for
you Active Directory admins,
you all know how
complex that could be.
So you have hundreds
of servers, probably--
dozens of hundreds of servers,
depending upon your company
size--
and replication
topologies, trusts.
You need to set up disaster
recovery, clustering.
So it's complex, right?
So as your company grows,
the whole infrastructure
becomes very, very complex.
So what's the deal?
So we have these two systems--
very costly, and then complex.
How to deal with that issue?
That's where Cloud
Identity hybrid approach
comes into picture.
It has the components that
helps you meet where you are.
We recognize you have these
on-premise applications.
And probably, you
may need more time
to migrate and modernize
those applications
or retire those applications.
Or in some cases, you
may want to continue
to use it for whatever reason.
What we want to do is we
want to provide the bridge
to connect all those
on-premise-based applications,
give a versatile solution
so that you can use
one single solution to integrate
your SaaS-based applications,
web applications, and also
on-premise-based applications.
What it does is
it basically helps
you reduce the cost of ownership
and also, most importantly,
reducing the complexity
that's associated
with on-premise
enterprise directories.
And then finally,
when you're ready--
for example, after
some time when
you're ready to move
some of your applications
and infrastructure
and move it to cloud.
Maybe you're doing
a lift-and-shift.
The key thing is you don't
have to make any changes that
are related to identity.
So it'll be a seamless
transformation-- so one
less thing to worry about.
So now let's zoom
into Secure LDAP.
As I said, so this is one of the
key component in Cloud Identity
hybrid approach.
What it does is it's
an LDAP-as-a-service.
So imagine you have a bunch
of LDAP servers in the cloud,
except you don't
have to set it up.
You don't have to manage it.
You don't have to patch it.
It's all done for you because
it's a managed service.
So what it does is it
actually takes your Google
directory, your users,
groups, everything, and then
it basically makes it available
as a joint LDAP directory
for your on-premise-based
applications, legacy
applications, that
talk LDAP protocol.
And if your applications are
talking to an LDAP directory
for authentication,
authorization, user lookups,
group lookups--
no matter how you use
your LDAP applications,
so this can be that LDAP
application in the cloud.
And another key benefit is
regardless of where you have
your applications-- it
could be on your on-premise,
it could be in your private
cloud, public cloud, Amazon,
Google, Azure, it
doesn't matter--
so the access will
be very smooth.
Now, let's look at a
pictorial representation.
So this is the most
simplified version
of an on-premise infrastructure.
So you have some
applications there.
You have IT infrastructure, like
VPN servers or RADIUS servers,
network attached servers,
and then printers and things
like that.
And also, you have desktops.
So traditionally,
they all connect
to Active Directory, or one
of your LDAP directories
like OpenLDAP.
So what you can do
is, using Secure LDAP,
you can go to
those applications.
And then there, you can
onboard these applications
into Cloud Identity
within minutes.
You'll be able to
see in a few minutes.
You onboard those applications.
We generate digital
certificates for you.
And then you'll be able to go
to individual applications,
upload the digital certificate,
go to the directory settings,
and just point those
applications to Secure
LDAP as your LDAP server.
And that's it.
And the most
important thing here
is no user change
management required.
So if they're used to seeing
same kind of login pages,
if you're logging into
SAP or a VPN solution--
so they'll be seeing
the same login pages.
So behind the scenes, instead
of your servers talking
to an on-premise
Active Directory,
they'll be talking to Secure
LDAP for authentication
and directory needs.
So this is another scenario.
So traditionally, when
you lift and shift
some of those applications
onto the IaaS platforms,
so you generally throw in
some VMs for Active Directory
because you want to
support those applications.
And again, it's not
one or two servers.
So probably, you will end
up setting up multiple VMs.
You need disaster recovery,
so you throw in more servers.
And if you're a
large company, you
have users in multiple regions.
So now you copy and paste the
same setup in multiple regions.
And then now, if you have
LDAP-based applications,
you might also need load
balancers before that.
So what you have done
is the complexity
that you currently have
on-premise with your directory
servers, you just replicated
the same kind of complexity
in the cloud.
It's a double whammy now, right?
So it became even more complex.
So again, you can avoid all
that by simply integrating
your cloud workloads
directly into Secure LDAP
so that you don't need any
of those Active Directories
out there.
However, so we
recognize that there
are some applications
that explicitly
need Active Directory--
for example,
if you have Windows
servers, or maybe you
have a SQL server or SharePoint,
other Microsoft applications.
So for those reasons,
we've announced
today something called Cloud
AD, which is a managed AD
service that you can use.
So in summary, the
key benefits are
you can use one identity
and access management system
to integrate both your
modern applications
and also legacy applications.
And you can reduce
the dependence
on on-premise
directories, which will
help you reduce the cost
and also the complexity.
And then finally, it gives
you the Google scale,
Google performance, and also
Google-based reliability
when you use Secure
LDAP and Cloud Identity.
Secure LDAP is
generally available
starting November of 2018.
So we have a lot
of our customers
who are already reaping the
benefits of Secure LDAP.
It's available in
Cloud Identity Premium.
If you are a GCP customer,
you start with the base Cloud
Identity.
All you have to do is add on
Cloud Identity Premium, which
allows you to use Secure
LDAP and many other features
that we discussed previously--
single sign-on and a bunch
of other identity and
access management features.
And if you're a
G Suite customer,
if you have G Suite Enterprise,
all these capabilities
are part of G Suite Enterprise.
If you're using G Suite
Basic or Business,
you can simply add on
Cloud Identity Premium
on top of what you have.
And if you're an
education customer,
it's part of G
Suite for Education.
These are some of the
Secure LDAP partners.
These are the companies who
work with us very closely
to integrate with Secure LDAP.
And PaperCut is one of those
partners who are in this room.
And these are not
the only applications
that work with Secure LDAP.
So you can pick any
LDAP-compliant application.
You'll be able to
integrate with Secure LDAP.
So let's switch to a quick demo.
In this demo, I'm
going to show you
how you can onboard an
application within Cloud
identity and also how to
point that application
to point to Secure LDAP
and see how it works.
OK, so for those of you who
are GCP customers or G Suite
customers, this is a
familiar admin console
where you manage users,
groups, and applications.
And I'm clicking on Apps.
This is where you manage
all your applications,
single sign-on-based
applications, OpenID Connect.
These are the
LDAP-based applications
can be managed here.
So this is the list
of applications
that I currently have.
And I click on Add LDAP Client.
In this case, I'm
integrating PaperCut.
So in this screen, you'll be
able to apply access control.
So you can decide
how much you want
to expose your directory
to this LDAP client--
in this particular
case, PaperCut.
So for example, if
PaperCut is used
by only a subset of
people in your company,
all you have to do is--
let me find this
mouse pointer here.
All right, I got
my mouse corner.
So you click on Selected
Organizational Units,
and you can decide which
part of your directory
you want to expose.
And if this application is
used by your entire company,
you may want to expose
your entire directory
for authentication.
And you can decide
these access controls
not at the LDAP client level,
but for each transaction.
So the first
transaction is verifying
user credentials, which is
the authentication part.
The next one is user lookups--
same thing.
So if you want to
allow this application
to do user lookups for
your entire directory,
you click on Entire Domain.
And then you can also
decide whether you want
to expose your groups or not.
Now, I'm clicking
on Add LDAP Client.
Within a few seconds, we will
onboard this application.
And we're also generating
a digital certificate
that can be used.
And click on go to the
LDAP client details.
And I'm switching
on this service.
So once the application
is switched on,
it's available to accept
requests from PaperCut.
So now, the part two
of the configuration
is you need to go
to PaperCut, and you
point PaperCut to use Google
as your LDAP directory.
So this is their admin console.
Here, you'll be able to see
a bunch of LDAP directories.
Select Google Cloud Directory.
If you're configuring your
own LDAP applications,
don't worry if you don't
see Google Cloud Directory.
You can pick any generic
LDAP option there.
OpenLDAP, That should work fine.
And I've typed in
my domain name here.
And then I'm uploading
the digital certificate.
And the digital
certificate is uploaded.
And I'm clicking
on Synchronize Now.
What's happening
is-- so now, PaperCut
is authenticating with Google
using this digital certificate
that we just uploaded.
And once it
authenticates, it was
able to make calls and do
user lookups and group lookups
using the LDAP protocol.
And this is the admin use case.
The other use case
is the end user.
So they can walk up to any
multifunction printer that
are managed by
PaperCut, and they can
type in the Google credentials.
They'll be able to release
all those print jobs.
So that's the end user
use case for PaperCut.
So if you've seen this, it took
less than about five minutes
for us to configure PaperCut
or any other applications.
All you need to do is make
sure you understand where to go
and where to punch in the
details to point to Google.
We have very detailed
documentation
on how to configure
all the partner
applications on our website.
And we do have some
generic documentation
if you have any other
LDAP application
you want to configure.
DECLAN HOGAN: Any of you
ever flown on AirAsia?
No?
Not you, Edward.
[LAUGHS]
OK, so let's get to the--
so we were established
in Malaysia in 2001.
Tony Fernandes bought an airline
for one Malaysian ringgit,
which is about $0.20--
$0.25?
It got two planes and
$10 million of debt.
So since then, we've put
on another 200 aircraft.
And we carried about 90 to 100
million passengers this year.
We have 120 destinations
or more-- fly everywhere
from Jeddah in Saudi Arabia
to Hawaii and everywhere
in between.
And we have about 25,000 staff.
And it's actually nine airlines
in five different countries--
so Malaysia, Philippines,
India, Thailand, Indonesia,
Japan-- so five or six.
Oh, OK.
So that's us.
We are currently on
Active Directory.
And it's on-prem
And each country
will have its own DC,
and they will all sync together.
They're all supposed
to sync together,
but that's not
necessarily how it works.
It is extremely
challenging to manage.
And we really
wouldn't be changing
if the auditors hadn't killed
me every time they do an audit.
And when they do IT
general controls audits,
they always find
people who exist in AD,
who had left the company from--
the HR system said
they left X days ago.
They're either
still in AD, or they
were removed from AD
days, weeks, months
after they left the company.
So that's a security
challenge, an audit challenge.
And it's just too
hard to manage.
We have PowerShell scripts
running between HR applications
and AD to pick up users,
configure them in AD,
push them to multiple
other systems
that they need access to.
And it's by the grace of God
if that PowerShell script
works, doesn't work, fails,
fails at a particular record.
HR may have given the
person a different email
address in the HR system
than we give in AD.
It's just too hard to manage.
Why did we go with
Cloud Identity?
We didn't really go with Cloud
Identity, we went with Google.
So we're migrating
all our apps onto GCP.
And we currently have
on-prem, colo, private cloud,
SaaS, AWS, Azure, Alibaba.
We have applications everywhere.
That sounds like
a very enlightened
multi-cloud strategy,
but it's not.
It has evolved that way.
And yeah, it's too
much to manage.
And we have 215-odd
applications that
are spread over all of
those hosting methods.
So yeah.
Anybody else got
similar environment?
[LAUGHTER]
A couple of hands went up there.
Yeah, OK.
Good.
And when you saw, it was
reduced dependency on AD.
We don't want to
reduce dependency,
we want to get
rid of it entirely
out of our organization.
We want to get off
our enterprise license
with Microsoft.
We have got Gmail, G Suite
for every single user.
We are pushing everybody
onto Chrome devices.
We're even contemplating
turning Windows devices
into Chrome devices.
And we'll have a
crack at Neverware
after this conference.
I see a couple of guys
from the data team.
So there-- boys.
So they're big GCP
users, big Data Studio.
They love all the Google tools.
So we're pushing
the whole company.
So it's an enterprise-wide
transformation
to get people off the Microsoft
stack onto the Google stack.
And we're in a
hurry to get there
because our enterprise
agreement expires next year.
So we want everything on GCP,
everything authenticating
through Cloud Identity, every
user getting off Microsoft
Office products by
the end of this year,
so that we're not at the edge
of a cliff when our enterprise
agreement expires.
Let's see.
OK.
Well actually, I will go back.
And the one biggest
challenge there--
Microsoft Excel.
That is absolutely
the one challenge.
The rest of moving
clouds, lift and shift,
building native on GCP,
that's all quite easy.
Using Cloud Identity and
spinning up applications
and pointing them at Cloud
Identity, that's easy enough.
Getting rid of AD, that's
actually not too bad.
But getting people to give up
their Microsoft Excel is like--
is-- we have a team
who all they do
is go around, trying
to kill Excel.
And they make people cry.
They make grown
adults cry every week.
[LAUGHTER]
So don't try and do that first.
Leave that till last.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Yeah.
So cloud native-- we
want everything on GCP
because we have too many clouds.
And we have too much stuff
spread all over the place,
and we just want to consolidate
on one single cloud.
We're not too worried
about whether we
need a dual cloud for DR.
If Google loses
the world, then we
will be in trouble on that day.
But right now, if
somebody digs up
a piece of fiber
outside of our building,
we're in bigger trouble.
And these two are
laughing because that
has happened last year.
Yeah, so it's not so
much that Cloud Identity
is the key driver for our
digital transformation,
Google is.
And we went to Cloud Identity
because it's your identity
product, not because we went
through an exhaustive search
and soul searching,
decided it was best for us.
It's your product.
We're pushing everybody
onto your products.
We're pushing all our
stuff onto your cloud.
And we are working with Google
to work through all the kinks
to make it work.
Cost savings--
cost savings there
is your enterprise agreement.
Right now, we're carrying
the enterprise agreement
for Microsoft.
And your-- I don't know.
What do you call the
Google licensing agreement?
But we're carrying both.
We will not save a penny
until we kill one of them.
And that one of them is
the enterprise agreement.
OK, challenges-- I think
all I've talked about
is challenges so far.
But again, single
source of truth.
We have an HR system which,
through the magic of PowerShell
scripts, tells us who
joined and who left.
And we push that
through AD, and then use
that to kill access in all
of these downstream systems.
And it doesn't really work.
It works most of the time.
But if an auditor finds one
guy in an audit, that's it.
I failed the audit.
IT general controls audit is
a high finding against me.
Legacy apps-- we have
legacy going back to the day
Tony bought the airline.
Because it's an airline,
so you are always
carrying applications
which are--
you have a illegal compliance to
use an application which works
on a particular technology set.
And if that vendor
says, I don't support,
then he doesn't support.
And we have to keep
using the application,
so we need something
to fill in that gap.
PaperCut-- I would rather we
didn't use PaperCut by just
killing all the printers.
But I'm not allowed to do that.
So we do need
something to allow--
we have a FollowMe printing now.
And we need something
that allows that to work.
And PaperCut is a good
product, and it does that well.
But heads up, men.
I want to kill paper.
So once I get killing all of
this legacy Microsoft stuff,
we'll be going after the paper.
But I think I've been
saying that for about
10 years in companies
I've worked for,
and we still buy printers.
SPEAKER 3: That's
actually our goal, too.
DECLAN HOGAN: Yeah?
OK, good.
Good.
OK, that is the ultimate goal.
So yeah, AD, it's like Rasputin.
You keep putting bullets
in it, but we can never
actually kill it.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's a race to kill
it before it kills me.
[LAUGHTER]
And that's why we picked--
we picked Google, not pick--
well, I hate this.
Sorry, Google recording this.
But we did not pick
Google because we
thought it was the most mature
and the best product set.
And the whole
company cringed at me
when I started making them
use G Drive and G Suite.
But we found that
Microsoft did not
care about making Active
Directory that much better.
They did not care about
my general controls
audit findings.
They cared about selling
me their licenses
or selling us their licenses.
And Google, they will come
and say, yeah, you know what?
Our product is not
that mature now.
They know they're fighting
against AD in just 99%
of all companies, but
they are willing to fill
in the gap between
where you're at now.
And even we will give
them systems where we
don't have any documentation.
We don't know what
the system does.
And sometimes, we don't
even know where it's hosted.
But we just give it to Google,
give it to their partners.
And Edward there, he's just
knocking over those systems one
at a time.
How many have we
done so far, Edward?
20 or so?
More?
EDWARD: Yeah, it's
more than 20 now.
DECLAN HOGAN: Yeah,
so we're maybe
20%, maybe a quarter of the way
through where we need to be.
And we have to get there
by the end of this year.
Is this our environment, Edward?
This is the cleanest--
[LAUGHTER]
--version of our environment
that I have ever seen.
Wow.
RAVI KIRAN KUMAR: We put a
little [INAUDIBLE] on that,
so it shined up a little bit.
DECLAN HOGAN: Wow, yeah.
If we look like this,
we don't need you guys.
[LAUGHTER]
We'll stick with AD.
But yeah, it's a hell of
a lot messier than that.
And there's even
applications in there
which we don't go through AD,
we just go here and log in.
We have a single sign-on
system that we custom
built many, many
years before my time.
And sometimes, it talks to AD.
Sometimes, it doesn't.
Some systems are just too
old-school that we just
say, here user, go and
figure out how to log in.
Manage two passwords.
We don't care if it never
expires, just work it out.
But that's the nicest item I've
ever seen of our environment.
RAVI KIRAN KUMAR: And in
many cases, what we see is
it's even hard to know how
many applications you have.
So when we talk to
our customers-- like,
hey, tell us how many
applications are talking to AD.
They'll say, good luck.
So I'll come back
after three months.
So because there's no
application inventory
management and things
like that, so you
have these applications
floating around in spreadsheets
all over.
And then you have
these spreadsheets
with application owners
and then individual admins.
So that's it.
DECLAN HOGAN: Yep.
And the boys over
there will tell you we
restructure every six months.
And departments come and go.
They go off and be
their own companies.
And then they come
back into the group,
and then they go back out again.
And we're having to
change domain names for--
let's say we've spun off
our ground handling company
into a separate company and
a JV with a Singapore ground
handler.
So overnight, 5,000 staff
worked for a different company.
They still need to authenticate
back into our applications,
because they're doing the
ground handling for us.
They had @airasia.com email
addresses at midnight one
night, and then at 12:01
they became @gtr.com.
They still have
all our hardware.
They're still doing work for us.
They're still wearing shirts
with the AirAsia logo on it,
but they're a separate
company, separate HR system,
separate payroll,
separate policies.
And we have to manage that
happening quite a lot.
And that's happened
over the last 10 years.
So when people leave
those other companies,
we don't always know about it.
So we're relying on--
and so sometimes,
it's even the HR person has to
send an Excel spreadsheet to us
that we have to then load.
And you give that
to an auditor, it's
like shooting fish in a barrel.
So yeah, but nice diagram.
I wish it was like this.
OK, this is getting
more like it now.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so we're going
to kill all of that.
CRM system is Salesforce.
HR system is Workday.
So Salesforce, no problem.
Workday, problem
now, but soon to
be not a problem because
we're working hard.
We find that we
spend a lot of time
bullying the third-party
vendors to talk to Google.
Google are very good at
saying, OK, we'll do it.
Please try and make
your vendor do it.
So Workday are one
of those vendors.
So technology is ready.
It's contractual.
We're waiting for
contractual issues
to be resolved
before we can just
hook it through Cloud Identity.
And we find that with the
smaller vendors where we're
their biggest client, it's OK.
We can bully them.
But for the big guys, yeah,
we kind of need Google.
And having Google
as a partner who
are willing to do that for us,
that works really well for us.
OK, App Engine-- so the
dev team are happily
building stuff on App Engine.
So that stuff gets hooked
in fairly natively.
VPNs-- again, yeah.
This stuff is fairly standard.
We are moving everybody off
those Windows environments,
again, on desktops.
We are pushing people
onto Chromebooks.
Again, more people are crying.
But we just bribe them with
Pixelbooks, and they like it.
But once that Microsoft
enterprise agreement goes,
all of those Windows
licenses for those people
to sign into those
machines will disappear.
So we will need an
emulator to allow
Wintel tech at the
back end hosted
on GCP to talk to a user.
We will use
[? Suspass ?] and Citrix.
We will have RDS licenses,
which we'll still
need that RDS piece to talk
to that back-end Wintel.
We will either just consume
that license from Microsoft
ourselves, or we will build it
into Citrix and [? Suspass. ?]
And we will use [? Suspass ?]
as well to do the single sign-on
and the password
management piece.
And eventually, we have to pick
Citrix because of one legacy
or one of our most
important applications.
It's too important for us to
do it while trying to make it
work on [? Suspass, ?] so
we need Citrix for that.
A little bit of complexity,
but not too bad.
OK, benefits-- so yeah,
we're going everything
on GCP, absolutely everything.
The one caveat is China.
So 20% of our passengers and
revenue comes out of China.
I won't ask any Google people to
comment on their China strategy
here, but our issue is
more on bad actors in China
coming at us and trying to
hold inventory on our website.
So anybody else here
work for an airline?
No?
Well, the problem for
us is that in order
for us to sell you a seat on the
airline, we have to make sure
we hold that inventory
before you give us the money.
And because that
inventory is finite--
there's only 180
seats on a 320--
a bot will come along, hold that
entry, pass us a fake payment,
hold that seat for as long
as the bank comes back
and tell the payment is refused.
So that might be seconds.
It might be minutes.
We will wait up to 15 minutes
for the bank to respond.
And they will hit a
plane, one flight,
tens of thousands
of times, dominating
all of that inventory and
not allowing a real person
to actually buy the seat.
They will take that
inventory, advertise it
on a third-party website,
like an OTA site in China.
So if they're
holding it at $100,
they will advertise it at $150.
They will wait until
somebody gives them $150,
then they will give us $100.
And then four hours
before the flight departs,
they will drop any
inventory that they haven't
held because they can't sell.
We have to legally stop selling
four hours before the flight
departs.
And we've been having this
problem for two years,
maybe longer--
[? Sadesh, ?] longer--
where a flight will look
like it's got no seats left.
They'll all look sold or
held, but it will take off
with the flight half empty.
And that's a massive
hit on our revenue.
And those bad guys are
coming from inside China,
so we need a WAF inside China
that can see the traffic
right from the origin.
So until Google get
their armor product
to be a real AI-driven WAF
tool, not just an IP blacklist,
then, yeah, we're
stuck on Alibaba.
Ease of management--
I think I've
described how we currently
manage through AD,
and that's not very easy.
So we want that single pane
of glass, single console,
everything managed through it.
And we want GUIs like that.
I don't want to be having to
dive down into physical AD
boxes in five
different countries
to see why a profile
exists in one place that's
supposed to be gone.
And that's just a nightmare now.
Security concerns-- yeah,
the security concerns are--
because we keep having these
IT general controls issues,
all of those people,
if they're in AD,
they're inside the network.
If they're inside the
network, they have access
to data and systems.
And if they are bad actors
and through omission by us
they have access, then
our data is insecure.
We cannot have that happen
in this day and age.
So that needs to
be fixed this year.
And cost saving-- simple.
Just kill that
enterprise agreement.
[MUSIC PLAYING]